comment vous apprenez que vous êtes
soupçonné je suis arrêté tout simplement
direct comment ça s'est passé ils
viennent chez vous alors je suis donc
ces deux jours après les attentats de
bruxelles d'accord je suis chez moi à la
maison j'ai un ami qui me propose
d'aller chercher un pote à frère à lui
donc à l'aéroport je devais aller
chercher parce que les avions étaient
déroutés vers liège avait plus d'avion
qui descendait à bruxelles
d'accord donc du coup je l'accompagnerai
j'ai rien à faire donc ok je te suis on
monte dans la voiture on prend la route
indeed qui prend sa soeur également pour
l'emmener faire des cours du soir
et là on est pris en filature par la
police on le savait pas et on arrive
devant une déviation il ya une jeudi une
déviation parce que on m'a demandé
qu'est ce que je faisais devant le
palais de justice on passe devant le pas
de justice parce qu'il ya une déviation
il y avait des travaux dans les tunnels
ont tout simplement c'est pour ça que je
me retrouve devant le palais de justice
et là d'un coup une voiture banalisée
débarquent par la gauche
une autre en cercle et là je vois des
des flics à ce moment là je n'ai pas que
c'était pour les policiers mais des
hommes armés qui sortent un du gros
calibre et qui mettent leurs cagoules
je vois des vêtements couleur kaki qu ça
me faisait penser à des militaires pas
des militaires et là je n'ai pas le
temps de réaliser ça va mais ça va très
vite en fait donc pas le temps de voir
les brassards et c'est moi je me suis
content j'ai vu une chose c'est un
policier en face de moi avec une
mitraillette et donc vraiment un fusil
d'assaut et qui me faisait et qui me qui
tremblaient et et moi je suis là et un
silence de mort bien cherché et je me
lycée mais c'est la fin je vais mourir
en fait directement je me dis c'est fini
quoi le regard de ce mec je n'oublierai
jamais et il tremblait et donc si vous
faites attendre le lever vos mains
réflexes dans la voiture on sait pas ce
qui se passe il ya silence de mort donc
du coup à partir de ce moment-là lui
même mon pote il dit ça c'est des flics
les flamands ils sont en train de
paranoïa et donc instantanément glv même
un la soeur de mon pote elle était
tétanisé elles arrivaient pas et on lui
dit mais lève tes mains et elle était là
elle n'arrivait pas et du coup ça va
très vite mon pote
il lui tape dans la vitre à gauche il le
faut extraire par la vitre moi on me
demande de sortir par la gauche
j'essaye de sortir et un mec à droite
kim d'études
ce pas une balle dans la tête tu ne
bouge pas et du coup je suis resté là
jeudi à entendez-vous là moi je bouge
plus donc et je suis resté comme ça ils
m'ont demandé de sortir par la droite et
ce qui m'étonnait en fait c'est que mon
pote ils ont directement attraper sa
soeur ils ont directement mises dehors
et moins il réagi il y avait une
distance comme ça de 2,3 m je comprenais
pas c'est vraiment une peur etc bouge
pas bouge pas bouge pas fait attention
chaque ne fait pas de geste brusque et
c'est vraiment cette situation qui qui
qui faisait que en fait j'ai intérêt à
les écouter si je veux pas que cette
balle arrive dans ma tête quoi tout
simplement c'était ça dans le quoi
j'étais concentré écouter ce qu'ils
disent et fait ce qu'il faut faire
enfin réagi calmement pas de geste et
donc je mets ma main
donc il me demande ouvre la porte de
droite j'ouvre la porte de droite et là
ils disent vraiment pas de geste brusque
qui est d'abord ton pied donc je sors et
là je vois un tireur d'élite un peu plus
loin avec je vois de la lumière qui nous
tapaient dans les yeux et en fait
c'était un policier qui était avec un
tireur d'élite qui visait qui me
disaient clairement et ils sont autour
de moi et me vise avec eux leurs armes
et il ya un silence et je comprends pas
donc moi même je met les mains sur la
tête
enfin les films je les écarte les jambes
et et là il me demande de mettre au sol
et ils sont ils sont toujours autour de
moi avec une distance je comprends pas
donc je me mets au sol tu écartes les
mains j'ai peur que vous avez une
ceinture d'explosifs
sauf que c'est plus tard que je déçu
parce que à ce moment là directement il
ouvre le coffre de la voiture et là il
me tutoie plus ils vous voient c'est
monsieur acier vous ça va bien se passer
calmez vous et je me dis mais en fait
ils disent il n'y a pas de bombe il n'y
a pas de bombe il n'y a pas de bombe
je comprends pas et donc je retourne et
je vois le coffre et cherchent ils sont
concentrés dans le coffre de la voiture
donc à partir de ce moment là il ya une
tension comme ça qui est tombé et je
leur ai dit écoutez ici on est cool
depuis le départ donc aussi faites en
autant fait en temps calmez vous et donc
il me demande de mettre au sol et me
mettre des bandeaux sur les yeux et on
est emmené manu militari un parent dans
des voitures